[MUSIC PLAYING]
NIALL MELLON: And
hello, Googlers.
Thank you for taking time
out of your lunch break
today to hear about our
story with Mellon Educate.
It all started for me in 2002.
I went on a holiday
to South Africa.
And when we left the main
international airport heading
for the city center,
I was shocked
by the size tens of
thousands of shacks abutting
the side of a modern motorway.
I was fascinated and
disturbed by this sight.
And my girlfriend and I had
rented a house in Cape Town
for a couple of weeks.
And after a couple
of days, I said
to the guy who was looking
after the house for us,
would he mind bringing me
to the nearest township.
I wanted to see who were
the people who were living
in these terrible conditions.
The first thing
he said to me was,
white people don't go
into these townships,
and look, it's better
off, you stay out.
It's too dangerous.
And if you want to do something,
donate a bit of money,
but really it's not a
good idea to go in there.
And being a stubborn
Irishman entrepreneur,
I pushed him a bit
further, and he gave in.
And four minutes later I was
in a township with a lifestyle
maybe 300 or 400 years
different to the one
I was living in the
house that we had rented,
and it was only
four or five minutes
away from where we were.
I started out probably
very similar to everybody
here in the room with my
own dreams and ambitions,
and one of the first things
that really hit me was how--
I think all of us as we
progress through our career,
when we overcome one obstacle
or we achieve one achievement,
we take on a bigger
target in front of us.
And all of the people that I met
in this township, none of them
had dreams that
even went a fraction
as far as mine had gone.
And I met the local
community, and I
walked around this township.
And the first thing
that surprised me
was how friendly
everybody was to me.
There wasn't the-- there
wasn't the fear or intimidation
that I had felt I would
get going into a township.
Once I said a warm
hello to people,
I got a warm hello back.
I asked that community was
there any way I could help,
and they said to me-- this
was 15 years ago-- that they
had a number of school-leavers
who had qualified for college
but didn't have the means
financially to get to college.
And that was the beginning of my
connection with this township.
I ended up sponsoring a number
of students through college.
And a short time afterwards we
were still on the same holiday,
so it had to have been
in the first three weeks,
I met the community
leaders and I asked what
was the situation with housing.
This community of 12,000
people on 24 acres
had built a total of six houses
in the previous 12 years.
So the sum total of
effort of 12,000 people
was one house every two years.
And I asked to
meet the community,
and the following day I was
brought back and put on top
of a number of wooden pallets.
And I found myself speaking
to a few hundred local people.
And I said to them that
if they were willing,
I was willing to work with--
if they were willing for me
to work with them, then I
was willing to try and see
could we improve the
housing situation.
So we launched a
housing program,
and I committed to building
450 houses over three years.
And I was still on a holiday.
And soon afterwards,
I found myself
in a rented car with a
wheelbarrow in the boot of it
and looking at how we were
going to start this project.
I spent a couple of
months planning it.
And shortly after we started
building the houses, maybe
two weeks afterwards
the police arrived
into the township
looking for me,
and word had got around Cape
Town-- it was now on the radio
that this guy on a holiday
had started building houses
in one of the townships, and
the police said to me, look,
we understand what
you're doing here.
You're big hearted,
well-meaning,
but you're going
to get killed here.
You're not going to live
more than two weeks.
The gangs are going
to kill you, and look,
you can't come in with no
experience as a foreigner
and just help.
You just won't last.
So I went back to
our rented house
and weighed up that
for a somber evening,
and maybe it's the stubbornness
of being an entrepreneur,
but I said to
Nicola, my partner,
that well, look, I've
said I'm going to do it,
so I'm just going
to do it regardless,
and hopefully things
will work out OK.
And after a short time
building the houses,
it really dawned on me that this
is an experience that everybody
should have in your
lifetime, maybe
not to make as big of a
life changes as I have made.
But what if people
could just decide
to give six or seven days of
your life helping poor people?
Wouldn't that be amazing?
Even if we went back to
our own lives afterwards.
So I announced a volunteer
trip, and the first year I
aimed to get 150 people.
And maybe half of them I
personally twisted their arms,
and I did a couple
of radio interviews.
But 150 people signed up,
and the second year we
were thinking what would we do.
And we said, look, why don't we
just try and double our target.
So we doubled it, and then
we doubled it and doubled it
and doubled it, and five or
six years later our trips
had gone from 150
to 300, 700, 1,400.
And by 2008, over 3,000 people
applied to come on our trip.
I decided to host all
of our trips on one week
every year instead of doing
maybe 20 little trips.
In 2008, we had almost
2,000-- over 2,000 people
took off from the
London airports here.
We had to charter our
own jumbo jets for the--
we couldn't get
enough seats on planes
to bring them all
down to Cape Town.
And on one day I
stood at the airport,
I wanted to shake hands
with every person who
was decent enough
to come and help
the mission that I had started
that now became our mission.
And over 19 hours I shook hands
with over 2,000 volunteers.
Our charity within five years
became the largest housing
producer on the
continent of Africa,
and all fueled through a spirit
of collective volunteerism.
Maeve mentioned Nelson Mandela.
And I was very privileged--
I'm not sure of the exact
date, but within a year or two
I got a phone call
through somebody
that Mr. Mandela
would like to meet me.
And he was really fascinated
how so many people
from this part of
the world would
come and volunteer to help
people they had never met.
And he really was full of such
admiration and appreciation
for the efforts that all
of our volunteers had made.
So when we look at our
housing program now,
our official figure is 125,000.
But we are probably
closer to 200,000 people
are living in houses built out
of the toil and sweat of people
same as I see here
in front of me today.
Three-quarters of
all of our volunteers
have no specific
building trade skill.
They just have big
hearts and a desire
to enrich their own lives and
make a difference in the world.
In 2007, USA-- or maybe it was
2006 I met the United States
government, and USA
applauded the efficiency
of our housing charity.
They said to me they thought we
were the world's most efficient
housing charity, but
they said they wouldn't
be able to help us unless
Congress voted to assist us,
that on a technical
position on their structure
they weren't allowed to give
money for permanent dwellings,
even though they
said they could spend
$25,000 on a tent in Kosovo,
but a permanent structure
was just a technicality.
And two years later,
one of the first pieces
of legislation passed by
the Obama administration
was a law in Congress directing
US aid to support the Mellon
Township Initiative.
We've achieved great
impact in South Africa.
And when we first started,
the national housing subsidy
per house per family
was 1,000 US dollars,
and the Mellon
organization started
to build a house for $10,000,
a really good-quality structure
that would in time
go up in value
and be an asset to a poor
family to build a better
life from a quality house.
Within seven or eight years,
the South African budget
had increased almost 1,000%,
and now throughout South Africa
it is effectively
the Niall Mellon
house that is built
throughout the entire country.
The house that is now in the
South African National Housing
Program is effectively a
copy of the Mellon house
that we started to build.
Three years ago we
looked at ourselves,
and we were at a crossroads.
And we said, well, do we
take a path in the back,
and do we recognize we've done
something special in housing
and call it a day and go
back to our ordinary lives,
or do we try and
build on the magic
of collective volunteerism and
do something in another space
where a lot of help is needed?
And we decided we would
get into education.
It's probably singularly
the biggest single space
on the planet where people
in poverty and developing
countries need help.
And we decided as
a strategy that we
would spend a couple of years
slowly learning about education
to try and find the sweet spots,
the special spaces that if we
could get help from
talented people,
that we really could
make potentially
a global impact with
our education program.
I set a personal mission
to go and visit 100 schools
and to sit with the parents,
the teachers, the school
principals, the
governing boards,
and ask thousands of questions
and try and just spot the gap
where maybe help could--
large-scale intervention with
a twist on the existing program
might lead to
something very special.
So we've started a
couple of initiatives.
Firstly, we need
help from people
to help us build
good quality schools.
If you're not in a classroom
that's dry from the rain
and safe and secure,
children can't study
to the best of their capacity.
So the first thing we do
in the Mellon organization
is make sure we built
a structure that's
fit for purpose.
The second part we
do afterwards is
we try and train the
teachers up to a standard
to achieve a much
better performance.
So we looked around some
of the schools in townships
throughout South Africa for
exceptional school principals
who had achieved results as good
as any top school in the world
anywhere.
And one of the first
people we recruited
was a school principal who
went into a secondary school
of 1,500 pupils and
a pass rate of 27%.
In one year, he got it to
82% percent and in two years
to 96%.
We were really privileged
that he joined our team,
and talented people,
as you people know,
find other talented people.
And from that small base,
we recruited the beginning
of our education team.
We looked at South Africa, which
deserves an awful lot of credit
for what she has achieved.
It's very easy to
look at the things
that South Africa is not
doing maybe as well as she
should, but overall--
and I've learned a lot about
South Africa in the last 15
years.
I would be an enormous--
an enormous fan of everything
South Africa has achieved.
She's 23 years old
as a democracy.
She's putting in more
money into education
than any other developing
country in the world.
She's putting in over 6
and 1/2% of her entire GDP
into education, and that
compares to European countries
at approximately 4 and 1/2%.
So she's putting in
between 1/3 to 50%
more than European countries
are putting into education.
But she has inherited an
enormous backlog of problems.
Many South African teachers who
specialize in English, maths,
and literacy under the
old apartheid regime
were never trained in the
subjects that they're teaching,
and we frequently meet teachers
who for 25 or 30 years in a row
have never achieved a pass
rate in maths of over 5%
in their subject.
But South Africa's trying to
embrace everybody and move
forward, and we've--
we have a new process
beginning where
we've asked South Africa to
take some of the money she's
spending on teachers,
some of the money
that they spend on the remaining
parts of a school budget,
and give that to an
organization like Mellon
where we can run some
schools ourselves,
which hopefully will become
real starship examples of what
can be achieved with a less--
a less maybe-- less inherited
approach to school management.
So we have now taken over the
management of a few schools
that the Mellon
organization are running,
and in less than 12 months the
difference in the performance
of our schools is staggering.
We've achieved an
improvement of almost 50%
in our first 12 months in
our first couple of schools.
But we have much,
much further to go,
and we won't be able to get
there without help from people
like you listening
to me today who
have the knowledge and the
mindset to help us to scale up.
One of the areas that we are
really interested in doing
is capitalizing on
the human goodwill
that we have experienced
over the past 15 years.
Everywhere we go
throughout the world people
are full of love and goodwill.
We've had over 22,000
volunteers, which is remarkable
considering that 50% of them
came from the UK and Ireland,
and each of those people raised
between four and 6,000 pounds
to come with us.
And together we
changed the landscape
of a country of 50
million people on housing.
And we need your help today
to do this on education.
So the area that we
are looking at now
is how innovation and e-learning
can accelerate our program.
And what we see as
a major gap that--
now, maybe you guys will find
it, where we haven't seen it.
Maybe somebody is doing it,
but we haven't seen it so far.
And that is connecting retired
or active school teachers
in developed countries with--
and mentoring
teacher-to-teacher,
body-to-body, volunteering
teaching program
with teachers in
developing countries.
If I put this into context,
in the United States
we have approximately 3
and 1/2 million teachers.
Here in the UK we have
approximately half a
million teachers.
In the United States,
75,000 teachers
retire every year and
proportionately similar figures
in the UK.
If we get one hour a week
from 2% of the teaching
community in the United
States or the United Kingdom,
that will immediately impact
in a transformational way
four million children
in South Africa.
So to improve the lives
of four million children,
we just need one hour
a week through 2%
of the teaching community in
the United States and the UK.
And how do we do this?
We do it through technology,
and the biggest deficit areas
in education in South Africa
are literacy, mathematics,
and language.
37% of children in South Africa
who've been in school for six
years cannot read.
37% cannot read after being
in school for six years.
Now, how little time
would it take not just--
I'm talking today
about teachers,
but imagine if it was just
people like yourselves
and ourselves who are trained
up in a little bit of literacy
coaching.
There's so many skilled
literacy programs
where amateur people like
ourselves can actually
sit and read a book
over the internet
using technology to a child
or a pupil at the other end,
and that child's education is
going to change dramatically.
What I learned
through volunteerism
was the impact of large-scale
collective volunteerism.
In South Africa
initially there was
a curiosity, about
150 volunteers coming,
a bit more interested,
300 the following year,
a lot more at 700, and
then when 1,400 came
on one go, an enormous impact.
And then when over 2,000
came into a city of a couple
of million people in Cape
Town-- in the evening times,
it's a first-world country where
the people you meet on the trip
that-- during the day when
you're working with them,
you're go out to
restaurants in the evening.
So all the taxi drivers
are meeting our volunteers,
and the city gets
an enormous boost
at the end of such a week.
We use our one week
every year to leverage
inspirational goodwill for
the incumbent government
in South Africa.
So we invite ministers
and leading politicians.
And for most of the time people
are critical of politicians,
and maybe in some
cases deserve it
but not in all cases, that I
see the sincerity and integrity
of a lot of people working in
the South African structure.
And maybe what our trip does is
just send a message once a year
that there are many of
us around the world who
care about the
effort you are making
to improve the lives
of your people.
On the last occasion that I was
ever to meet Nelson Mandela,
I had the cheek to go
to him and tell him
I wasn't coming to
see him anymore.
And he posed for a
few moments, and I
thought had I overstepped
my mark here, me telling him
I wasn't going to come
and see him anymore.
But I meant it in a nice way,
that he was an elderly man,
advancing years, and
I felt he should just
be left for some special
time in his remaining
years with his family.
And I said to him that
maybe not one of us
could fill your footsteps,
but together there
are many thousands
of us who can.
And I said to
Mandela that you can
rely on me as one
of your lieutenants
to continue the journey
that I've started,
inspired by people like
you and other great South
African leaders.
And when we parted, Mandela
reached across the table
and held my hand and said
that I should never forget,
that everything is
possible through the power
of the collective
effort of people.
And the Google-- the Google
business-- the Google journey
is extraordinary.
In the history of the
world, has there ever
been companies like
Google that have
been able to have had and
achieve such a global impact
on all of our lives.
We are living in a very
uncertain and turbulent time
in the world.
You all know what's happening
between the United States
and North Korea and
what's happening in Syria.
And I think there have been
very few moments in history
when large-scale volunteerism
has been as important as it
is now to balance the
great progress we've
made in the world.
What better message we can
send to struggling nations
than large-scale
volunteering trips
that serve to inspire and
deliver greater progress
in those countries.
So we have two requests of
you today that some of you
might consider coming out
on our volunteering trip.
Debs is going to talk
a little bit more
about that in a few
moments, and it's
one week out of your lives.
But I can truly say to you it's
a week the memories of which
will never ever leave you.
It is so humbling and special
to meet some of the poorest
citizens on our
planet and to hear
their dreams and their
ambitions and help
improve the chances of those
dreams becoming fulfilled.
We need help then on
the technical side.
We are a very small charity
who's achieved great impact.
But now we're a new charity
starting in education.
We need your help to promote
Mellon Educate to help
us promote volunteerism and
recruit more volunteers.
What if-- instead of
2,000 volunteers coming,
what if over the next
two or three years
we have a moment with
5,000 volunteers arriving
in South Africa?
What would be the ripple
effect of such a positive trip
like that?
On the innovation
and technology side,
imagine how a large-scale
internet-based volunteering
program could affect the
lives of millions and millions
of children so easily.
And one hour a
week is all we need
from people in developed
countries and particularly
teachers initially
to benefit children.
And so I'm going to leave you
with one last story of my times
with Mandela, which perhaps
this story will demonstrate what
Mandela meant to the world, and
in a way what South Africa's
success means certainly
for Africa, if not
for the whole planet.
One time I was with Mr.
Mandela and another friend,
and I was asked to
meet this young guy.
And Mandela said, now you
tell Niall your story.
And this guy said to me,
well, I was a young boy of--
I can't remember exactly.
I'll pitch to this,
I'll be slightly wrong.
But approximately
12 years of age when
the war broke out in Rwanda.
And I can't remember if it
was on the Hutu or Tutsi side,
but the other side
came into his house.
And in front of him, they killed
his parents and all of his five
or six brothers and sisters.
And this young boy
went down to the elder
in his village terrified,
and said, what do I do?
They've said they're going
to come back for me tomorrow.
And the elder said-- it
was just when Mandela
had been made president.
And the elder said, if you
can get to South Africa,
you'll be safe.
Mandela has just
been made president.
And you have to get
to South Africa.
And that little boy gathered
his underpants and I think two
T-shirts and a little
bag, and he walked--
or probably got a train--
train journey or hitched
posts along the way,
but he made it over
3,000 miles simply
on the inspiration of what
Mandela could do for him.
And Mandela's
legacy has been one
of embracing everybody
at the same time
as trying to help
his own country.
South Africa has
never been given
enough credit for the
fact that she has kept
her borders open to refugees.
Several million people have
found a home in South Africa
in the 23 years of the new
democracy in South Africa.
And it is vital to the
continent of Africa
that we help South Africa
to achieve true success
as quickly as possible.
And the ripple effect of that
will reach an entire continent.
So I hope I'll see some
of you in South Africa,
and maybe some of
you might have ideas.
Together maybe we
could potentially
form a Mellon Educate Google
team on the innovation
side that might be able to
help some dinosaurs like myself
to find a better way to quickly
get through that innovation
opportunity and create
a platform that will--
that will give an opportunity
for teachers to help
our children in South Africa.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]